- Pets love us unconditionally
and they don't judge us.
Being up here and having
a place for the dogs
makes all the difference in the world.
I know you're happy.
I'm glad.
- Dog mountain in the Dog Chapel
is an open dog park where
dogs can really connect
with nature and enjoy
spending time outdoors
with their owners.
And having a place like the Dog Chapel
really helps people say goodbye
or also leave a little message
about how much they loved them.
It was basically started
by artist Stephen Huneck.
And he said the worst
thing he ever heard is,
“It's just a dog.”
That's why Stephen built the Dog Chapel
to memorialize these wonderful creatures
that have touched our lives so much.
We've got people that pilgrimage
from every state and every continent
just to bask in the walls of the chapel
and leave a little message behind.
They take comfort in knowing
that those pictures and those messages
will be here for years to come.
- I think dogs can bring
out the best of us.
And yeah, it's horrific to say goodbye
but that's true of so
many loses in our lives.
There are some places of reverence up here
I think for a lot of
people, however they choose
to recognize that.
- Dogs are really special
and it's one of a kind place
that we have here that
allows dog to really shine
and be cherished as the wonderful
little creatures that they are.
(peaceful music)